soir or mercredi prochain le 10 mai ce
sera la journée nationale de l'esclavagé
la traite négrière
une bonne raison pour vous inviter
joseph ndiaye vous qui êtes conservateur
de la maison des esclaves de l'île de
gorée au large de dakar au sénégal
d'ailleurs à cette occasion vous publié
chez michel lafon un livre qui s'appelle
il fut un jour à gorée l' esclavage
raconter aux enfants alors vous vivez là
bas vous vivez là bas toute l'année
joseph un mes origines sont goréenne
ouais ouais donc vous y êtes resté
à l'orgue aurait à l'époque d' esclavage
c'était la porte de l'enfer l' enfer
pour des millions d'africains déportés
aux amériques et aux antilles pour
travailler jusqu'à l'épuisement dans des
exploitations de coton de sucre de de
tabac de café des millions d'hommes
sacrifiés est ce qu on sait combien de
dom sont partis là bas de caisse un
train six premiers et sky pour tous guez
à 10 58 des révolutions esclavage par la
foule d'après nos archi de riz à ikea 20
millions de noirs le tout la figure et
ce qu'ils ont quitté cette île de gorée
où les amériques voilà alors des
millions d'hommes donc sacrifié pour la
richesse des colons évidemment mais
aussi pour le confort des sociétés
occidentales qui grâce au commerce
triangulaire se sont beaucoup enrichi à
l'époque en fait ouais bien sûr
l'esclavagé existait déjà au temps des
grecs et des romains et en afrique mais
là les noirs qui étaient raflé était
considérée non pas comme des êtres
humains mais comme des comme des objets
ou comme des animaux comme du métal
comme des bêtes de somme a uni ses yeux
et des fois dans cette maison des
secrets j'ai trouvé toute une famille le
père la mère et l'enfant déjà séparé des
cellules il faut avant lui aussi ça
dépanne aussi des acquéreurs 1 le père
pourrait diriger sur la ligier nous us à
la mer au brésil au combat la faillite
ou les antilles la séparation était
totale une partie de ces titres ou des
numéros de matricule et jamais sous le
nom rafik dans les plantations et mails
ils opteraient pour l'un de leurs porte
métaux blancs aux usa vous avez seynoise
américains qui ont des noms à enlever au
brésil portugais kova espagnol haïti
anti-français nos prénoms français c'est
donc du nom d'emprunt qu'ils
actuellement et donc des noms d'origine
africaine
alors vous raconter l'esclavagé vous
raconter le voyage des esclaves ranger
dites vous dans des call comme des
cuillères c'est à dire qu'on essayait
d'en mettre le plus possible dans l'est
dans les cales d'un des bateaux de tran
est de l'eau sur 60 de large il à mettet
350 à 400 il a même été beaucoup plus
foireux le plus d'hommes valley d'alarmé
un sur cinq qui mouraient pas le voyage
sur scène
et c'était pas très malin des s'il est
maltraité d'autant que la valeur de
notre dépendance aux poils de sa
musculature en somme l'homme perdait
toute sa valeur marchande puis l'état
dans lequel étaient soumis c'était très
mal c'est pour ça que souvent ils
s'arrêtaient par exemple en guyane pour
les remettre en forme avant d'aller les
vendriez engraisser comme des oies ouais
alors il ya eu des révoltes mais toutes
les révoltes étaient vraiment mal léché
ouais à part une sur laquelle spielberg
a fait son film bellamy stats
alors vous raconter toussaint louverture
la première république noire de
l'histoire à haïti du sien le 28 ou
savait que ses origines c'est un tsonga
aux mains c'est à dire la petite bible
et menin elle aurait baissé son arrière
grand père fut capturé et à moyen et à
haïti alors lui aider haïti il n'est pas
né au bénin il est à haïti alors c'est
lui qui évidemment a fomenté cette aide
révolte c'est lui qui a bâti en premier
chef les enlever et les français la pole
et on a invité alors en france en visite
officielle c'était un piège qu'elle n'a
pas les installer alors il a hâte et
j'ai sur le fort de jours ou les mois je
suis parti à nous trois ans plus un bel
hommage dans la cellule et m'ont tous
élus accusent de faim de froid
voilà et puis après il ya les mouvements
abolitionnistes qui commença à se mettre
à l'oeuvre jusqu'à l'abolition de
l'esclavagé mais qui est extrêmement
tardive tardive avec avec victor
schoelcher n'a reconnu française - en
2001 quand même madame taubira a fait
passer une loi il a fallu attendre 2001
qui reconnaît la traite esclavagiste en
tant que crime contre l'humanité oui
parce que majorque descendants de fabry
d'esclaves
nous a dédié nous en tant qu'un tuner en
cargo bourré une grande statue à
l'entrée de la maison esclaves à
desdunes ventre ça tu as la mémoire de
nos ancêtres qui ont été déportés
en 2005 et les excuses de jacques chirac
nous pardonnons mais n'oublions pas
parce que l' esclavage n'oubliez pas que
l'esclavagé a duré 300 ans détient 130 6
à 2,58 et j'ai dit souvent qu'on parle
beaucoup des cadres de concentra l'ojif
que le respectons nous en tant
qu'africain les cadeaux qu'on s'attache
à gilles ne repasseront plus de 12 ans
le trait du nord 2 300 en trois siècles
on apparaît presque jamais et bien en
tant que conservateur cdu de ce sentier
africain qui est la maison club de
bruges en paraît toute ma vie j'avais
fait un sacerdoce
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que vous avez appris qu'en
france y ait une loi qui a été tenté il
ya quelques mois sur le rôle positif de
la colonisation outre-mer
oui j'ai dit souvent que
esclavage
colonialiste sont là deux sociologues
qui ont le même objet l'exploitation
duras par une honte pour aller plus loin
donc aucun rôle positif au cours de
positif
vous avez fait la guerre pour la france
vous oui j'ai débarqué j'ai connu la
france à partir de toulon en 44 n'a pas
attaqué aux travailleurs sénégalais
ouais vision la première armée oui après
la libération mais j'ai opté pour les
paras et je suis parti avec bigeard au
vietnam c'est incroyable que la personne
qui habite à gorée et qui perpétue
le sentiment anti esclavagiste et était
avec bigeard se bat contre les
indochinois quand même que vous avez une
reconnaissance de la france vous avez
une pension militaire vous êtes parce
que oui c'est ça se sait le grand
jeu c'est le
la tache noire parce que jusqu'ici la
france n'a pas répondu à notre appel
nous touchons à la pension mais pas à
égalité avec nous nos amis français un
mois je tire le traité sous-officier
dans les pachys français mais si je vous
dis que je touche lui fois moins qu'un
parachutiste
ses excuses on sait tous qu'il est fait
pour partie à gorée là
oui je vais avoir et je retourne chez
moi je suis avec mon épouse jeanne est
pour jusqu'à rose jusqu'aux pour
chirac a besoin de moi et je suis
invitée j'ai répondu à son appel
dans tous les cas merci d'avoir répondu
aux nôtres
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu